from Sify originals to hard-hitting
dramas and superlative horror films the
year 2017 delivered a bumper crop of
excellent flicks for film lovers the
year was so chock-full of cinematic wins
that some critics have had trouble
trimming down their lists of favorites
even so there's no doubt that these
movies are part of what made 2017 such a
memorable year for movies split pretty
much no one saw it coming but M night
Shyamalan surprised hit split is among
the best films of the year the taut
thriller follows a group of young women
abducted by a man with multiple
personalities their struggle for
dominance threatened to either upend his
plans or make things even worse for his
captives everybody just take a minute
critics have hailed it as an unexpected
return to form for Shyamalan and a big
part of the film's buzz comes from its
twist ending it isn't just the shocking
final act that makes split so much fun
actor James McAvoy ties it all together
with a tour de force performance get out
helm by debuting feature director Jordan
heal this comedy horror hybrid follows
the increasingly frightening
misadventures of a young man venturing
into the suburbs to meet his
girlfriend's parents the fact that
they're an interracial couple
underscores both the funniest and
creepiest moments of the film and soon
our hero finds himself under the town's
sinister spell just as the dangers of
his hosts become clearer
sorry man there's a reason why
everyone's been talking about get out
since its release see it yourself and
find out why Logan
although Hugh Jackman has been
celebrated for his portrayal of
Wolverine for better part of two decades
none of those outings have truly
captured the angst and rage that helped
make the character so poignant in the
comics that all changes with Logan a
loose adaptation of the old man Logan
comics arc that finds our hero in a grim
wasteland largely devoid of mutants
called upon to defend a mysterious girl
targeted by a passel of bloodthirsty
villains a brooding western roadtrip
with claws Logan's been hailed by
critics as a fitting farewell for
Jackman and perhaps the best entry in
the x-men franchise to date Beauty and
the Beast Disney's winning streak
continued in 2017 with the box office
bonanza that was their Beauty and the
Beast live-action remake the faithful
remake of its animated predecessor was a
must-see for movie fans because it
introduced a new all-star cast updated
visual dynamics and a few new songs and
end jokes to enjoy it was a rare movie
that could truly be enjoyed by audiences
of all ages and arrived as one of the
year's most successful movies as a
result Wonder Woman after 75 plus years
of taking down baddies in the comics
pages and one supporting appearance in
donç justice Wonder Woman finally got
her shot at solo blockbuster glory in
2017 and she may have single-handedly
saved the DC extended universe
Wonder Woman did everything it needed to
and then some serving as an effective
origin story as well as a superhero
adventure that stood on its own while
continuing to lay the groundwork for
Justice League considering how
underwhelming Justice League turned out
to be
it looks like Wonder Woman is going to
be carrying the DC EU on her very
capable shoulders from here on out baby
drivers with its eclectic soundtrack and
insanely impressive stunts Edgar
Wright's baby driver is an exciting
action flick the pic centers on a young
crook named baby who works as a getaway
driver for a smarmy crime boss named Doc
suffering from tinnitus baby drowns out
the constant droning with an incredible
collection of iPods and while he's
grooving to the tunes he's able to weave
in and out of trash
dodge cars and avoid police pursuit by
doing 180s in alleyways but babies life
gets a little more complicated when he
falls head over heels for a beautiful
waitress which makes him want to
straighten his life out but he's got one
more job on deck working with a who's
who of psycho killers needless to say
the robbery doesn't go as planned and
baby is forced to take a stand to save
everything he loves with its dance-like
action and it's cool character lineup
the film has got a little something
special for everyone and arrived as an
immediate standout for the year Dunkirk
of Christopher Nolan's greatest
achievements Dunkirk is right up there
with inception in The Dark Knight the
nail-biting world war two thriller tells
the story of a real-life military
retreat roughly 400,000 pallet troops
were trapped on a French beach
completely surrounded by the Nazis and
the only thing keeping our heroes from
home was the English Channel
unfortunately the beach was too shallow
to accommodate military sized vessels so
English civilians sprang into action
sailing to Dunkirk and their yachts and
fishing boats it was an incredible
moment in history and no one does a
masterful job of capturing the suspense
in true nolan fashion the story is
divided into three interwoven narratives
which are all ultimately connected
audiences are put in the middle of the
battlefield and feel the same
desperation of those soldiers waiting
for a boat to arrive with a chance of
rescue
hits and English yetis it isn't the
first adaptation of Stephen King's witty
novel in 1990 Tim curry made horror
history by playing penny wise the
dancing clown the dairy demon with a
fondness for floating with Bill
skarsgård wearing the carnival makeup
things are a lot darker and bloodier in
the new tank the first of a two-part
tale it tells the story of the losers
Club a group of outcasts kids who are
beaten by bull easy and plagued by
horrible home lives but when they're
together these kids are pretty powerful
and they need as much strength as
possible when they find themselves
facing a flesh-eating clown the losers
eventually head into the sewers to end
the evil that's been plaguing their town
for years and under all the gore and
grime behind the monstrous apparitions
and evil sinks there's a lot of heart in
this movie even if the creepy clown
wants to eat
Bladerunner 2049 while it's become one
of the most influential sci-fi movies
ever made
when Blade Runner hit theaters in 1982
it divided critics and flopped at the
box office 35 years later dean eva
louvre sequel has been similarly
unsuccessful at the box office but it
completely impressed critics with its
stunning visuals and intensely
philosophical plot the film's dynamic
landscape feels equal parts terrifying
and fabulous and even beyond the
gorgeous imagery is a movie still
grappling with and building on the same
meeting themes from the first film
namely the nature of humanity with Ryan
Gosling as k.a Blade Runner hunting for
answers about his past and the truth
about the Android race known as
replicants the story explores the depths
of the human soul so while the film may
not have been a commercial success this
time either we can count on Blade Runner
2049 to inspire the sci-fi scene for
generations to come as well I Tania
directed by Craig Gillespie I Tania is
an examination of what really happened
in 1994 when ice skater Nancy Kerrigan
was attacked before the US Figure
Skating championship in Detroit and how
one woman was at the center of it all
Tonya Harding played to perfection by
Margot Robbie Harding comes off as a
tragic antihero caught between an
abusive mother a violent husband and a
desperate need to succeed in a snobby
sport that treats her like dirt and you
should pick another sport suddenly
surrounded by creeps and idiots
she claws her way to the top only to see
everything come tumbling down fast you
might already have an opinion of a
notorious ice cream but thanks to
Robbie's powerful performance we
actually come to sympathize with this
woman who's so often reduced to a simple
trashy villain Star Wars the last Jedi
while it's controversial among some Star
Wars fans the last Jedi cleaned house at
the box office and used its force powers
to win the approval of almost every
critic in the galaxy picking up pretty
much immediately after the force awakens
the film finds Rey desperately trying to
convince a world weary Luke Skywalker
that the resistance needs his help but
the old Jedi is holding on to some
secrets and refuses to leave his
deserted planet frustrating Rey and
causing her to seek answers from her old
enemy kylo Ren in addition to the main
plot
the last Jedi takes us to some
incredible new worlds and pays homage to
the originals while setting up an
exciting new future for the franchise
thor ragnarok for the most part the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has delivered
solid entertaining films with the
exception being the Thor franchise while
the character always had potential the
first two films didn't quite do justice
to the god of thunder
so thank Onan for Taika Waititi who's
Ragnarok is an apocalyptic good time the
plot follows store as he's trying to
stop hella from taking over Asgard
unfortunately Thor's superhero plans
don't pan out and after his hammer is
crushed into tiny pieces he finds
himself imprisoned on a planet where
he's forced to do battle with the
Incredible Hulk what results is possibly
the funniest movie in the entire Marvel
franchise and one with a surprising
amount of heart since I'm right it's
true unlike the previous two films
Ragnarok
actually has something to say about the
destructive influence of colonialism and
how great nations often hide their
bloody pasts and most importantly Thor
is no longer a Shakespearian straight
man instead he's a good-natured goof
who's forced to truly reckon with his
own godhood with a few werewolves and
fire demons in the mix phantom thread 10
years after there will be blood Paul
Thomas Anderson reunited with Daniel
day-lewis for phantom tread a period
drama that marks the last time day-lewis
steps in front of a movie camera the
story follows his powerful and obsessive
dressmaker who goes through women like
their spools of thread until he meets
his match with a waitress he turns the
artists life upside-down soon the
relationship goes from sweet to toxic
allowing day-lewis to unleash all his
thespian powers along the way while it's
lacking the fire and brimstone of there
will be blood
phantom thread is just as powerful and
it's suave and simmering mild-mannered
English Way and marks a fitting end to
day-lewis's illustrious career the
disaster artist widely considered one of
the worst movies ever made the room has
left audiences howling for years with
its bizarro scenes and nonsensical
dialogue courtesy of Tommy Weis oh you
are lying I nearly hit you you got a
partly shop an odd ballot or who wrote
directed and starred in this especially
awful film why Zell has long been one of
cinema's craziest and most mysterious
characters he's been treated as a
laughingstock in a villain but according
to the disaster artist maybe he's just
the ultimate embodiment of the Hollywood
dream directed by and starring James
Franco the film depicts the relationship
between aspiring actor Greg Sestero and
wise oh and out-of-control egomaniac
with incredible amounts of cash and CRO
ability to memorize lines action
what line wise Oh hopes to become an
a-list star but when he's rejected time
and time again he decides to make his
own movie sucking Greg into the world's
weirdest film shoot while it would be
easy to make wise L look completely
foolish Franco gives a much more layered
performance that's being called one of
his all-time best the shape of water
Guillermo del Toro is a master at
telling enchanting tales as seen in
films like Pan's Labyrinth The Devil's
Backbone and crimson peak and now the
director is crafted what might be his
magnum opus with the shape of water a
film that looks like Creature from the
Black Lagoon but feels more like Beauty
and the Beast
this film follows a mute janitor who
works at a government lab and discovers
an amphibian man locked away in the
bowels of the building despite their
very apparent differences the two form a
bond and soon there's a romance brewing
one threatened by Cold War intrigue and
ambitious military officer the result is
a truly magical movie with gorgeous
direction and moving performances from
its leading duo all the money in the
world
Ridley Scott managed to turn what could
have been a show-stopping scandal into a
point of positive buzz through sheer
force of will after Kevin Spacey was
accused of multiple accounts of
inappropriate behavior against minors it
seemed there wasn't enough money in the
world to save the directors true life
thriller but Scott quickly recalibrated
by recasting Spacey's role with
Christopher Plummer and reshot 22 scenes
with just six weeks to go until the film
was due in theaters not only did he
complete the ultra ambitious adjustment
in time but critics were also highly
impressed with plumbers misanthropic
performance as the billionaire who
refused to pay ransom for his kidnapped
grandson as a result the movie which
could have become a casualty of the 2017
reckoning was actually one of the year's
most impressive productions the post
based on a true story Steven Spielberg's
the post follows Washington Post owner
Katherine Graham and editor Ben Bradley
as they debate whether to publish the
Pentagon Papers leaked documents that
expose the US government's lies about
the Vietnam War with pressure coming
down hard from the White House the two
must grapple with concepts like the
value of a free press knowing full well
their decision could wreck the paperwork
or worse we could all go to prison an
old-school movie from an old
schoolmaster the post brilliantly jumps
back and forth from historical epic to a
comedy to crackling thriller the a-list
stars are on top of their game and more
importantly in an era when fake news and
divisive politics rule the day the post
is a timely reminder about the
importance of journalism thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
you
[Music]